hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are continuing
the match Fabiana Caruana versus alvarez
a few loose jump and we are skipping
game 2 and 3 as I don't know if I will
have time to upload them so basically
what happened is that Fabi won Game one
it's the game
we've seen then Fabi also won Game two
and then Alireza strikes back in game 3
and now ali reza needs a win in this
game at the force armageddon and to take
the match in two tiebreaks so let's see
what happened here Fabi with the white
pieces opens with d4 sorry about that
we've we have Knight to f6 by Fallujah
c4
we have g6 so the Kings Indian defense
is on the board Knight f3 and Bishop to
g7 and here g3 preparing to fin get to
the light square bishop we have castles
and Bishop to g2 now yeah we have these
six by holidays are in now castles and
here there are a lot of possible moves
here very very popular or 96 9b d7 c6 is
an idea but here we have a nice thief or
which is a very rare continuation so
Queen c2 goes after the night
immediately and now Fallujah just
cemented on e4 with f5 we have Knight B
to d2 now again challenging the night
and here early raise our trades we have
Knight captures Bishop characters in the
Nabi 5 so it's not new it has been
played some I guess some 30 times which
is which is very little considering
other variations are you know there are
over 3,000 games in the database
regarding some other and more popular
variations so d captures on e5 we have d
characters and Bishop to b4 now
attacking the rook here on f8 rook to e8
and the rook 8 d1
developing with an attack on the Queen
Queen to f6 and here Fabi brings back
the bishop the c3 where it will be much
more useful so Knight to c6 continuing
development and now nice T 1 here if
Abby wants to get his Bishop to b5 so a
for a moment he talks the knight back
into e1 and also Fallujah would like to
start pushing those pawns so he first
hand needs to move the Queen Queen e7
and Bishop to d5 with trip King h8 and
now Knight back there
three by Fabi as the bishop is now
nicely placed on d5 so the efore will
not close it in on g2 we have night to
be four now attacking the bishop but
basically preparing c6 to get rid of the
bishop so Queen b3 now if you capture
yes you can capture the bishop then
white gets a very nice pass and not a
passed pawn but a very nice D pawn
so instead we have nice to a6 just
getting the knight out of the way and
preparing to trap Coronas Bishop with c6
so here Fabi has to go back 91 so the
bishop can now retreat but now e for
future doesn't let it retreat and now
again he's threatening c6 to win to win
material and it's a very hard for Fabio
to find a move here how do you save the
bishop so here this is what Fabi finds
the Bishop captures on g7 Queen captures
in now c5 freeing the c-4 square for the
bishop and now c6 we push it back to c4
in now Knight captures and c5 grabbing
back the pawn attacking the Queen Queen
a3 and now Knight back to d7 so here
Fallujah is up upon and if he manages to
develop well his bishop and and the two
rooks he should be he should be okay but
it definitely is better now
due to the being upper poem so night the
g2 by Fabi and now Knight to e5
attacking the bishop on c4 centralizing
the Knight Bishop back to B 3 and now b6
preparing c5 and then worshipper to be 7
and so on so Knight to f4 also an
excellent square for fabi's night but
future doesn't give him a moment's
breath he just goes g5 attacking the
knight Knight to h5 attacking the Queen
and now queen g6 going after the night
and here is a very difficult position
for Fabi there's only one move that
basically allows Fabi to continue the
game so I will ask you to pause the
video here and find this move for Fabi
well I give you a couple of seconds so
for those who were able to do it
congratulations unsporting that well
spotting that the knight in fact cannot
be taken if you play the correct move
you can play something like G for free
the g3 square for the knight
a pawn and continue playing this game
but that's not that's basically resigned
so here what Fabi played this Queen to
d6 for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show now the point is you
cannot capture the night because of
Queen f6 checkmate as the Bishop covers
the g8 square and there's no way to put
anything in between the Queen and the
king so this would be checkmate
so future just continues developing the
shop to a6 goes after the e2 pawn rook F
the e 1 by Fabi end here future trades
Queens we have Queen captures rook
captures and now just look a to d8 again
going after the rook here rook to f6
going after the pawn and now better up
the c8 future just defends it rook to d1
now offers a trade of rooks and fallujah
goes for it we rook captures Bishop
captures and rook to d8 now going after
the bishop Russia back to B 3 and now c5
preparing c4 and again Fabi just defines
a nice unique move to keep the game
going Bishop to b5 now offering offering
the bishop
obviously for a nice checkmate on f8 as
the night covers the g7 square
so instead future continues with c4 this
knight Knight is nicely protecting it
now wants to start further expansion on
the Queen side so far be stopped set
with a 4 and now comes Bishop to d7 by
future also possible is just a 6 and you
continue pushing on the Queen set but he
goes for Bishop to d7 he attacks the a4
pawn but this gives Fabian idea now and
Fabi plays f4 f4 is an attack on one of
the defenders of of the d7 Bishop yeah
the other one being the rook of course
and here future has to play he captures
f3 on poisson there is no other way
around it and go into this character's
captures and now you're gonna grab your
f5 points so this is absolutely best for
fuchsia there is no other continuation
for him however he played the G captures
and I 4 instead and this allows Fabi to
just once again attack the defender of
the bishop here and there is not much
for for future to do now he attacks the
rook with 94 but now rub the d6 and now
you cannot move the bishop as you would
just lose the rook so here
93 attacking the bishop
but now just Bishop to e6 and here it's
it's a time to resign for future he did
play rook to e8 one more move to try and
maybe grab some material back but after
fabbi capture than b7 it was also in
this position that ali reza fuchsia
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here once the bishop is
captured the knight still covers the g7
square so rook to e8 will be rook to the
8 will be checkmate as their there is no
escape so after rook captures and e7
future resigned and another victory for
Fabiano caruana if i manage the time i
will show either one either game 2 or 3
or both of them as they were both
decisive and a very rare thing that we
will have all four decisive games in a
rapid match but yeah Fabiana wins the
match three to one but Fallujah was
extremely close to equalizing although
objectively he was better throughout the
entire game it was a hobby just found
some very very unique moves which made
it made it impossible for fugitive or
for any advantage and in the end Fabi
prevailed but yeah he's not the number
two player in the world for for no
reason
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
Jonathan star army Rotom Thomas filardo
Erik talking ttyn and the Callaghan
Cohan for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check too on my
previous videos here thankful for
watching and I will see you soon with
some more videos from the Magnus
Invitational and I will be covering it
until it finishes so thankful I will see
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day